hello everyone welcome to today's live
broadcast urine drug testing and pain
management presented by dr. William
Clark
I'm Christina Joel of lab roots and I'll
be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by lab woods the leading
scientific social networking website and
provider the virtual events and webinars
advancing scientific collaboration and
learning for more information please go
to WWE's comm we have a few important
announcements before we begin this
webcast is designed to be interactive
and we encourage you to ask questions
during the event you can submit
questions by typing them in the Q&A box
which can be found by clicking on the
green Q&A button at the lower left of
the presentation window we'll try to get
to as many questions as we can you can
enlarge a slide window by clicking on
the screen icon in the lower right hand
corner of the slide window if you have
any technical problems viewing or
hearing the presentation please click on
a support button on the top right of
your presentation window or submit your
problem through the green Q&A button on
the lower left this is an educational
webinar and thus offers free continuing
education credits after the webinar is
over please click on the Cee button
located on the bottom left-hand corner
of your webpage and follow the process
of obtaining your credits I would now
like to introduce today's speaker dr.
William Clark dr. Clark received his PhD
in analytical chemistry from the
University of nebraska-lincoln in 2000
followed by a postdoctoral fellowship in
clinical chemistry at the Johns Hopkins
School of Medicine pending in 2002 in
addition he received an MBA focused on
medical services management from the
Carey School of Business at Johns
Hopkins in 2007 following his
postdoctoral fellowship he has remained
at Johns Hopkins where he is an
associate professor in the Department of
Pathology
as well as the director of both
point-of-care testing and clinical
toxicology for the hospital dr. Clark is
board-certified in clinical chemistry by
the American Board of clinical chemistry
and is a
the National Academy of clinical
biochemistry I will now turn it over to
dr. William Clark for his presentation
Thank You Kristina so I appreciate the
opportunity to speak today and we'll go
over your drug testing in pain
management
before I begin I do need to show my
disclosure slide pain management testing
is heavily dependent on mass
spectrometry as a technique for
measurement we'll talk more about that
later
but I do have the two disclosures that
are pertinent research and consultant
support from thermo Fisher Scientific
and Xu monsoon so I want to start this
afternoon by talking a little bit about
the treatment of pain as this is
becoming increasingly important in our
in our society and in clinical practice
so when we think about the pain
management patients we want to think who
are these patients and it comes from a
wide variety of places we can think
about issues with folks from central
nervous system derived pain folks with
multiple sclerosis or Parkinson's
disease we have neuropathic pain or our
threated pain a lot of folks have
chronic pain both cancer-related and
non-cancer related pain and then we have
fibromyalgia depending on where you go
to get your statistics you'll see I have
something less than here where we say in
2002 almost half the US adults are a
little over 40% reported experiencing
pain for over more than one year some of
that's just a consequence of getting
older I find myself a little stiff
getting out of bed in the morning once
in a while and and so some of that is
dependent on pain tolerance but what is
definitely obvious to us is that more
and more people as we increase our
ability to manage chronic disease also
we see more chronic pain so when you
think about chronic pain physicians in
many settings may treat one of several
opioid drugs we have oxycodone oxycontin
we have methadone fentanyl hydrocodone
and the thing about the opioid drugs is
that they have a high potential for
addiction or abuse and so this is a
challenge for physicians because they
are treating this medical condition of
chronic pain but they're also giving a
drug that definitely can be abused and
in some cases where patients may misuse
the drug by keeping extra portions of it
to themselves
and then taking large bonuses of it as
opposed to taking it in multiple smaller
doses or they may divert it right in
this case what they may do is say that
they have pain they keep some of the
drug for themselves and they sell that
to either support a different drug habit
or it may be non drug-related behavior
and the other issue in pain management
patients is that the physicians need to
know whether the patient is taking non
prescribed drugs during treatment as
this can both be an indication of drug
misuse and abuse but it also can be
problematic in terms of patient safety
because of drug drug interactions if a
patient is taking an opioid drugs such
as oxycodone or fentanyl and then
they're taking also heroin illicitly the
additive effect of those drugs can be
can be fatal so when we think about
non-medical uses of drugs you'll see
from this 2012 publication of the survey
you'll see that pain relievers seem to
be the highest use of drugs in terms of
non prescription use over the ten-year
period shown here for people aged 12 and
older so pain relievers or pain
management drugs are the highest use non
prescription medication are non-medical
uses of drugs right now if we think
about the potentially fatal consequences
of this you'll see that in the early
2000s the number of opioid angel'
analgesic poisonings that that resulted
in death if you looked at death
certificates almost doubled in that
period from 1999 to 2002 and we also
find that in the same time period
poisoning from opioid analgesics
surpassed
cocaine and heroin as the most frequent
type of drug poisoning I can see some
statistics there from Florida where
three times more deaths from
prescription drugs than illicit drugs
combined and so we see this more and
more if you'll read the news you'll see
combinations of these now we find
certainly in large metropolitan areas we
see illicit drugs like heroin being
spiked with drugs like fentanyl or
fentanyl derivatives and so you know
this is something that has significant
and severe consequences if it's not
managed appropriately so as part of this
because of the the high abuse potential
but also the potential of fatal
consequences from mixing medications or
misusing these medications it's very
important to think about how we can
assess risk in these patients and deter
the abuse of these substances when we
look at ways to approach this we have to
think about it I'm I'm not a physician
on the laboratory but we we think about
it first from the physicians perspective
which is quite important in terms of how
they're able to integrate risk
assessment tools into their clinical
practice so in some cases they you you
have a multitude of tools that are
available to you but what's important
for the physician to remember is that
these tools for risk assessment that's
the first step and then the care plan
has to take into account these
components of the risk assessment so
that they can minimize the potential for
misuse or abuse on the drug so part of
this is a physical examination just you
know assessment of what is the nature of
the pain and then also thinking about
the history and both from a personal
history but also a family history of
abuse is there a history of alcohol
abuse in the family is there a history
of addiction in the family a
psychosocial assessment is taken and and
all of these these are behavioral and
environmental factors that are important
to factor into the assessment of risk
because both personal or family history
of drug or alcohol abuse seems to be one
of the strongest predictor
for the risk of abuse or misuse of these
drugs another important thing to to note
is that addiction is rare in patients
that are treated for acute pain with
opioids it really is it really is not
the addiction part in the short term it
really is something that can tend to
develop over a long period of time or
perhaps that addictive behavior there is
present prior to the treatment for acute
or chronic pain so some of the tools we
have that are we being that the clinical
community have we have these screening
tools that assess potential risks
associated with the opioid therapy and
there are some assessment tools or
interview tools that we have that some
of these are generally accepted the
first one being the screener and opioid
assessment for patients with pain
there's the original and both a revised
version this would be this is often
referred to as the soap tool there's
another tool called the opioid risk tool
and then there's the dyer instrument or
diagnosis intractability and risk
efficacy instrument the dyer tool is
clinician administer and so it's
designed to assess potential efficacy as
well as harms whereas the other tools
are based on self-report and i think
this is an important thing to know which
is self-report questionnaires well i
mean we can just say it candidly people
people lie particularly people that have
addictive behaviors or are inclined
towards these misuses and drugs they
tend to not be truthful with the
clinicians and so now this is a
challenge and and one of these tools are
deemed to be useful
there are definitely limitations and the
primary one being you know truthfulness
of the patient reporting so there
whether the the questionnaire whether
their physician it's administered or
patient self-reported tools are
important there are other tools that can
be used so so these these interview
tools are used for continual screening
and wrist data fication but there are
other things to do such as pill counting
so we know that we gave you 30
and you're coming back to me and you're
supposed to take one a day and you're
out after 21 days well that suggests
that you're either sharing those or
you're taking more than one pill at a
time and we can think about things like
prescription monitoring programs that
we'll talk about briefly where in this
case the the prescriber this is a report
from pharmacies which tell you the
prescriber of the date filmed how many
pills were in that prescription
what's the pharmacy name and the city
where the pharmacy is located and what
this allows you to do is a prescriber
then can access this report based on the
patient and find out if their doctor
shopping or pharmacy shopping and
getting pills from multiple sources
there one of the other tools is
education regarding drug storage and
sharing how we keep these pills away
from our children or away from our
spouses or siblings and then also other
psychiatric approaches as well one last
thing to think of would be an abuse
deterrent formulation so adding
something to the drug that that makes it
difficult to to doctor the pill or crush
it or making it difficult to to share or
if the drug is misused and perhaps that
can induce some sort of sort of an
illness I think one of the the approach
is not necessarily in pain management
but one of the the more widely known
approaches for abuse deterrent would be
the suboxone where you have the the
antagonist naloxone in Co formulated
with buprenorphine buprenorphine so that
if that suboxone is abused it will not
allow you to get too high or it could
even induce a physical response as you
displace the opioid from the from the
receptors so there abuse deterrent
formulations are one way also to to get
past this so what a challenge with
prescription monitoring programs is that
they're not the same everywhere right so
in some cases they may go from
scheduling schedule 2 through 5 and
non-controlled substances as you see in
the red states here on the map where you
go to some states where it's not widely
used
the blue states you'll see your schedule
only schedules 2 through 4 so it's not
the same and the other one is not all
states share information across state
lines and so I think that again
prescription monitoring programs are an
important tool but they don't
necessarily solve the problem of
inappropriate obtaining pain management
substances so one of the tools that is
available that's an objective tool that
where we want to talk about today is
urine drug monitoring and this is an
objective tool to monitor abuse misuse
or diversion from from a clinician
perspective we know that there are some
challenges in in doing urine drug
monitoring but it does provide an
objective measurement it's very
difficult to dr. although there are some
challenges there as well but it detects
the presence of particular drug or its
metabolites and that enables us if you
couple that with some of the risk
assessment tools and the clinical
presentation of the patients can give a
physician a better sense of whether the
patient is taking the medication as
directed now it's important to note that
this still has a ways to go because it
is used less frequently primary care
doctors or in some cases as we'll talk
about there are different tools that we
can use for drug monitoring and it may
be that primary care doctor is using a
typical immunoassay based screen that
will miss the presence of many many
drugs that are used for treatment of
pain and so it may not be used as
effectively as it could be and the other
limitation to the effectiveness of this
tool is depending on the laboratory
abilities the testing laboratories
ability to this detect what you're
looking for this goes back to many
Hospital labs don't have access to a
mass spectrometry setup and so if they
don't have n L CMS assay and they're not
using a reference laboratory they may
only detect a small portion of the
substances that are that are important
for poor pain management
another thing we have to think about
from a clinician perspective again not
from the lab perspective as well when do
when do we or when do they do the urine
drug test based on some best practices
that have been published certainly
initial testing is part of the risk
assessment it's important to find out
upfront before you start prescribing an
opioid drug is that patient are they
taking heroin or cocaine or maybe do
they have non prescribed benzodiazepines
on board that right up front would be a
red flag that perhaps this person is
prone to misuse of drugs and then after
the initial testing you can do later
tests for monitoring and that would be
based on the initial risk level and some
of those factors would be the soap or
other test testing tools that we
discussed earlier or it can be maybe a
standard procedure so in this case
perhaps for a low-risk patient you can
do a periodic eligibility or you can do
what we've listed here as I've just been
made aware of from interactions with our
pain clinicians that can be something as
simple as a random selection saying you
come in and you flip a coin or roll a
die and if you get a one through three
you get a urine drug test and so that so
that the patient doesn't feel that
they're being singled out based on the
interaction but this is really
randomized and that they participate in
the randomization so they know that it's
not rigged against them but whatever
whether you use random selection or
whether you use the self-assessment
tools the important part is to have sort
of a uniform criteria that's risk based
that enables you to explain to the
patients how they want to approach this
and you want to poach the urine drug
testing and and what your criteria are
for determining when they would be
tested and some practices are now using
in low-risk patients point-of-care
screening which are these urine cups
that can detect a wide range of
specimens but in those settings or
patient populations there are still some
limitations with immunoassay so if
point-of-care screening is used then you
should have at least one definitive test
which is we would consider
see mass spec or mass spectrometry based
test that should be done at least once
per year in addition to the
point-of-care screening so we'll move on
a little bit once we get through the the
clinician perspective in terms of what
is the role of urine drug testing or
toxicology testing in pain management
and when should that testing be done and
it really should be done at least semi
frequently in conjunction with these
other risk assessment tools but where
the challenges that we have from a
laboratory perspective so we think about
the role of the laboratory we have to
think about what it is that we're being
asked to do so in this case you know I
put this statement there there's
obviously no absolute assurance but
there is that sort of expectation it's a
burden and an expectation right it's
it's good that the clinicians have a
high degree of confidence in the
laboratory and they think that we can do
just about anything including the things
that they see on television or the
movies but so the expectation here is
that we need to give them absolute
assurance that the drugs that prescribed
prescribing can be are being taken
appropriately and the way we're asked to
do that as we mentioned is providing
this objective indicator of a patient
patients compliance with the treatment
regimen and we do this through either a
urine or a blood drug test the other
role though is we can't give them
absolute assurance obviously so that's a
little tongue-in-cheek but that sort of
rolls into the second piece which is our
our goal is to educate the physician
it's not just to give a number or
thumbs-up thumbs-down that the drug is
there we really need to be able to to
talk with them and help them with
interpretation if it's needed for some
providers that make that support might
not be needed but we want to make sure
that everybody's supported to the level
that they need we need to let them know
about you know some drugs what the
active metabolite is and and how that
needs to be interpreted but we also need
to make sure that they're understanding
the be limitations of the analytical
methodology what are they what are the
shortcomings of the immunoassay and and
where does what role does mass
spectrometry play in this type of
testing
so it's lab support for pain management
problematic there aren't a lot of really
good assays that are out there that are
standardized and commercially available
many of the immunoassays have problems
that we'll talk our way through the
country concentration cut-offs can be
challenging what constitutes a positive
result what you know is that should we
be using the workplace drug testing
cut-offs should we use forensic you know
driving under the influence types of
cut-offs what what cutoff should we use
for a positive test are these applicable
to the pain management population
oftentimes the the clinicians don't
understand what's the difference it's
either it's either there it's not there
and then we have to think about
adulteration and this is particularly
challenging I don't have a lot of
information in this particular lecture
but it's something we don't normally
think about it if a patient comes to the
emergency department they're sick and
they're not thinking about how to beat a
drug test they're just thinking about
getting treatment or they're not doing
well in a lot of cases they're
non-responsive or certainly not coherent
enough to be think strategizing about
how to beat a drug test but in pain
management it's different
these are ambulatory patients patients
that often are not in acute distress
they are patients in many cases that
know there's at least the possibility of
the urine drug test and if they have
smoked marijuana or used heroin or
cocaine or a prescription drug that has
not been prescribed to them they know
that they're going to be positive for
that substance and so we have to think
about that we have to think about things
like pill shaving into the urine to give
a positive test or perhaps taking a
bolus of drug immediately before so that
their urine becomes positive and there
are all sorts of things we have to think
about in terms of manipulating the the
toxicology testing result that we don't
have to think about in most other
patient population so I think that is a
real challenge that of course I don't I
don't have a great answer for you in
terms of how best to combat that
another thing that that's interesting
about lab support is you know there's
now all this information if we think
about how to in terms about specimen
types that are available we there's lots
of interest in dried blood spots or
dried urine spots and we know that
because of the adulteration we want to
observe to collection but there are you
know there are privacy issues with
observed urine collection and and most
of the urines that are collected for
pain management testing are not done so
in a Samsa compliant environment for
workplace drug testing so that you know
the toilet water is not blue and they do
have access to hot and cold run running
waters they can dilute their urine or
game the system and so there are many
challenges to those types of collection
but if you use oral fluid or saliva
that's something that can be an observed
but there are some some things that that
can make that challenging there are if
you look in the lower left-hand corner
of the slide you see blood specimens
there and blood testing is an
alternative but the detection window is
much narrower for blood and it is
invasive because it requires a
phlebotomy event and patients don't want
that necessarily and and then we start
to explore things like breath testing or
sweat testing and pain management
there's not a lot of evidence that those
are useful at this time but those are
options and and things that we'll have
to make sure that we're educated about
as laboratorians
because once that information is out
there physicians will ask about it and
in some cases for it something about
particular talent is with different
matrices for for pain management testing
well let's start with urine because
that's the most widely used sample and
when we think about the challenges with
urine some of that has to do with the
specimen timing and variability if it's
if it's a drug that's maybe taken once a
day if we think about relative of
collection because of well ative the
time of relative collection right so
when did they take the drug versus when
the time that we got the specimen did
they drink a large container of water a
couple of hours before a collection and
so they have taken the drug and that can
dilute it to below the cutoff that gets
back to the question of what's the
appropriate cutoff for pain management
we already have touched on observed
collection and then your earnest fairly
easy to adulterate and if you have some
time on your hands and and and want to
be amazed and perhaps entertained just
do some Google searches on different
ways to cheat or beat drug tests the
adulteration options out there just
available through the internet are for
me mind-blowing at the amount of thought
that goes into into trying to beat a
drug test so it would seem that the the
low bar or the the no-brainer would be
to say well let's go to the different
type of matrix maybe we'll try it with
blood but blood as we've mentioned is
invasive many of these drugs have short
half-lives and so that's an abbreviated
window detection that would require
proper interpretation would require
detailed or precise blood collection
relative to the precise information
around when the blood was taken and
there's no clear relationship between
the actual concentration of blood and
clinical effects so if we tried if we
tried to move this into the paradigm a
more traditional therapeutic drug
monitoring we don't really have good
tools for interpretation and it's not
clear that blood monitoring outside of
patients that have renal dysfunction or
you know aren't producing urine I'm not
sure that blood is really the way to go
for most of these patients and so again
the interest in oral fluid is increasing
but this is accepted in some quarters
but it's not a hundred percent well
characterized at this point the oral
fluid - blood drug concentration ratios
are variable dependent on the drug that
you're thinking about and they're
dependent on pH they're dependent on
protein binding if you see some of the
published data that are out here there
are live ranges of the oral fluid -
blood ratio between individuals the
paper I have here references in 2009
again the cut-offs or the reference or
therapeutic targets it's not clear what
those are and also there's not
it's not uniformly understood how to
collect the specimen some use a dilution
into buffer and then calculate the
dilution factor maybe from an optical
measurement of a dye and in the buffer
or in some cases that's weighing the
device before and after some of them
adsorb the specimen it's active
collection stimulated production of
saliva versus a passive drool collection
so a collection of the oral fluid or
saliva is not standardized either and I
think that could introduce variability
between laboratories and how to do this
testing and I just I think it's
interesting and it certainly helps with
the collection in terms of observing and
minimizing the adulteration risk but I
do think it's it's in my opinion it's
not quite ready for primetime yet but I
know that it is being implemented in
many different settings so it is - the
different matrices I mean there are all
kinds of types of samples we can test
but we also have to think about the
different methods alright so we have
here some point of care kits by
immunoassay and then we have liquid
chromatography gas and we have gas
chromatography coupled with mass
spectrometry and and all of these are
different settings that we can use to
detect the drugs and we have to take
into account again we have to be able to
understand ourselves what these methods
are capable of but we also have to be
able to articulate what are the
limitations and what's the best approach
for a particular patient population so
there are multiple technology platforms
each one has its own technical
difficulties and and the ones that are
most common are immunoassay screening
gas chromatography mass spectrometry and
then liquid chromatography mass
spectrometry we think about amino acids
one of the challenges is that the
specificity of detection varies with the
vendor for some things amino acids tend
to be somewhat specific where we have
something like a benzylic and an assay
for cocaine well that's that's pretty
standard but other assays like
benzodiazepines they're calibrated with
a different
standard for the for whatever the
qualitative cutoff is and that means
that the the the level of cross
reactivity for the wide variety of
benzodiazepines varies from vendor to
vendor on what you may or may not pick
up the other thing we have to think
about is what do they detect they're not
in most cases not specific to a
particular drug or metabolite benzylic
amine is more the exception than the
rule and in most cases if we take an
opioid a saying for instance it
primarily picks up morphine codeine and
then six Monticello morphine or heroin
thank you
so it picks up those particular
substances but then it doesn't really
detect oxycodone at a normal
concentration it's a very quite high
concentration and so we move to the the
middle of the slide here we do see that
oxycodone doesn't really react with the
opiate assay at low concentrations but
at very high concentrations at least say
in our laboratory at greater than 10,000
nano grams per mil whereas the cutoff
for morphine would be 300 nanograms per
mil it would take 10,000 nanograms per
mil to cross react but that is possible
right so we don't really know that it
could be a very high concentration of
oxycodone
it could be hydromorphone or it could be
morphine or even heroin and we don't
know the difference and it's a very big
difference between somebody taking
tylenol with codeine and somebody who's
shooting up with heroin right so the non
specificity is a challenge then we have
a couple other examples here on the
slide one is Fenna fibrate and
amphetamines and so Fenna fibrate is a
it lowers cholesterol like statins and
it's taken at a relatively high dose and
so it can get into the urine and cause
it's been published that it does cross
rec with amines and we have indeed seen
that in our lab in a cardiac population
then we have naloxone we'll touch on
this a little bit more a couple of
slides but we have seen that if someone
is being treated with naloxone there's
an antidote
antagonist for the opioid receptor if
it's in the urine or blood at a high
enough concentration it will cross react
with the assay and again somebody with
naloxone I mean I guess technically you
don't want them to have that that means
they're being treated for opioid overuse
but at the same time and that's if if
they were treated with naloxone that's a
little bit different than if they're
abusing a no peeling drug and then with
the amino acids also we're depending on
this qualitative cutoff for most
clinical amino acids it does have the
capability to do quantitative testing
but most toxicology screens be Amina
asked me that immunoassay are done
qualitatively with gas chromatography
mass spectrometry this is the gold
standard for toxicology testing and so
it's used primarily in confirmatory
testing and this is useful because it
can provide those structural qualitative
information for identification and it
can also give quantitative information
but many labs don't have access to the
equipment especially as we move forward
gas chromatography mass spectrometry and
a hospital laboratory is used less and
less for most of our confirmatory
testing we do send that to to a
reference laboratory in order to do gas
chromatography it also must be the
substance must be derivatized to make it
volatile if it's not naturally volatile
and so that requires a lot of specimens
pretreatment extractions derivatives
ations and follow-up extractions and in
a lot of cases you know make perhaps you
get a number it does have the ability to
provide quantitative information but
what does that what is that number mean
if we you know what is the cutoff that's
appropriate and what is the number that
represents compliant versus
non-compliant and I don't think well
some have posed solutions to this I
don't think that there's been an
entirely effective solution that I've
come across at last what's at least a
little bit more accessible would be LC
or liquid chromatography mass
spectrometry now this does I I place
here that says even more limited
although I would I would qualify that by
saying more and more hospital
laboratories aren't getting access to at
least part-time use of LC tandem mass
spectrometry but the difference between
gas GCMs and L CMS is that with gas
chromatography mass spectrometry there
are commercially available libraries so
there's a well-established library that
you can use for matching and and be able
to identify drugs but with liquid
chromatography mass spectrometry those
libraries are not widely available and
you must really develop your own
although that is changing some of the
vendors are working to make these tools
available but they're not widely used it
at this time and maybe a later review is
needed because there are shifts in the
chromatographic retention time with
liquid chromatography that are maybe
more pronounced and you would see in gas
chromatography but again LC tandem mass
spectrometry can give quantitative or
qualitative data but you must determine
again what are the criteria for
compliance or adherence so we're going
to talk a little bit more in depth about
two two of the technologies one is
immunoassay and so you'll remember that
with amino acids you have the imogen
binding site and so you're not looking
at the whole molecule in this case
you're looking at a structural region of
the molecule and because you're having
that physical interaction with with the
protein binding site or the or the
region of the the protein that has an
affinity for that particular structural
site there are molecules that would be
different and have different effects but
may have that epitope or protein binding
moiety and so that can be challenging
one example I wanted to give you in it
and it calls back to the naloxone cross
reactivity is we had this case study we
published in 2010 where a small child
was found abandoned unfortunately and
they were admitted to the emergency
department or transferred to the
emergency department yeah
at Johns Hopkins with decreased mental
status and possible hypothermia and they
we did use opiate amino acids to do
urine toxicology screening and the first
assay upon admission was negative and
after treatment we then found that the
second amino acid was positive and the
confirmatory testing for that positive
amino acid II was negative in other
words we did not detect based on GCMs
either codeine morphine heroin or any of
the other oxycodone hydromorphone so
there was something that was causing
that amino acid be positive delayed from
when the child was found and it was a
real head-scratcher to find out what was
going on with this patient what we did
find is a little more digging is that
that patient was given two locks own
they were given a bolus just before the
urine first year and was collected so
they got a shot right
but not the urine it was not far enough
away from the urine collection so they
it would have made its way to be cleared
into the year interest yet but then
after the first urine was collected in
addition to the bolus the the young girl
was given an optional oxidant infusion
and so in digging a little bit we found
that at very high concentrations
naloxone can cross react with the amino
acid and we confirmed this
experimentally in our laboratory you'll
see here that indeed based on a
follow-up report from the company at six
thousand nanograms per mil or micrograms
per liter it does turn the amino acid a
positive and so we sent the two
specimens from the young patient for
quantification and what to be fine we
found that the first was about between
three and five hundred nano grams per
mil and that the second specimen was at
almost 10,000 nano grams per mil which
obviously would cause the assay to turn
positive even though there was no opioid
drug
on board the patient so there it would
seem then the answer is well let's just
do mass spectrometry and there are
different ways to approach this we can
do selective reaction monitoring with
tandem mass spectrometry and a triple
quadrupole some laboratories are moving
more toward time of flight or
high-resolution orbitrap mass
spectrometry I think the challenge here
is that with triple quadrupole that's
that's equipment that more hospitals
have access to but it only
differentiates at nominal mass whereas
the time of flight were orbitrap
instruments they can get high resolution
mass up to three and four decimal places
when we look at the different modes we
want to think about targeted versus
untargeted screening do we want to
generate a number or do we want to
report just a positive or negative I
will tell you it are in our reference
laboratory just for our physicians we do
mass spectrometry based screening
because of the selectivity but we only
report positive and negative results we
do not generate a number that we we sent
to the clinician and it's important when
we're thinking about the mass
spectrometry to think about the
trade-offs what are the number of
compounds that we can detect with what
degree of reliability what the length of
analysis what's the sensitivity and
specificity and those are challenges
that we have to think about is where
we're trying to get this into routine
clinical use the other challenge with
the mass spectrometry based testing is
that there are many compounds that are
isobaric we just show one here set here
with the hydromorphone and morphine both
of which cross react with amino acid as
you can see I apologize for the darkness
of the slide I guess it didn't translate
from my slides into the into the viewer
but wait you'll also see is that they
have the exact same mass up to four
decimal places it's really just a
structural isomer so they fragment very
similarly and the only difference
between these two is chromatographic
retention is slightly different and
that's really important too well also
there's a
I shouldn't say that's the only
difference there's also a functional
group difference and that's what
contributes to the chromatographic
retention retention time difference and
so the way we approach this is we get
isotopically labeled standards for both
compounds and we run them so that we
know on that particular chromatography
column where each of the drugs is a
leading so that we can differentiate but
it is it is very difficult because even
monitoring the fragments they they tend
to look very similar so aside from
technical challenges then we also have
the challenges of interpretation and
it's it's important because again let's
let's go to it from a lab perspective
and from a clinician perspective and
from a clinician perspective there are
really three broad categories that we
have to think about number one is that
the prescribed drug is not detected or
in other words we prescribed the patient
oxycontin oxycodone and they are we are
not seeing the oxycodone precedent and
the specimen that indicates that there's
a chance that they're either diverting
the drug or they're hoarding the drug
and not taking it as as prescribed a
second category would be where we detect
an illicit drug so that we find that
they're exhibiting drug abuse behavior
and then last that a non prescribed
scheduled drug or a drug of concern that
may have synergistic effects with the
opioids particularly in the area of
respiratory depression depression is
detected and so if you think about it
from a clinician and these broad ones an
assessment of adherence and then also
non prescribed substances in the last
two categories what we find is that
absence of the prescribed drug and a
detection of illicit drugs should
required the immediate action in terms
of referring the patient to substance
abuse treatment also from the clinician
perspective and it's incumbent on us as
the laboratory to be able to communicate
this to physicians is to think about the
retention time or how long these drugs
stay on board the windows of detection
are this period when we say that or the
period of time after drug administration
we can actually detect the drug and we
have some examples most opioids we
really see two to three days but in that
means we'll only see for about two days
with 48 hours
cocaine and heroin have extremely short
half-lives and we'll see them 24 to 48
hours oftentimes it's closer to 24 hours
for these particular drugs of abuse and
something like marijuana if that's of
concern to the clinician will stick
around for three to six weeks the other
one is thinking about the metabolism so
here you see the metabolic pathway of
morphine and related compounds and one
of the things that is challenging is if
you look at this particular slide we see
morphine which can be prescribed as MS
Contin we also know that hydromorphone
and hydrocodone can also be prescribed
and so you'll see that if we see
hydromorphone in the sample that while
it's a minor metabolite if somebody's
getting high-dose morphine you may see
the hydromorphone and then the question
becomes well if you see hydromorphone in
the absence of morphine you know what is
responsible for that pattern so it's
really important to be able to talk
through those metabolic pathways with
clinicians to see what's consistent it's
it's it's very difficult to say
definitively based just on urine drug
testing levels that a patient is
compliant or non-compliant but it is
possible to say whether a pattern that
you're seeing based on the metabolism
it's consistent with compliant behavior
or non-compliant behavior another thing
to consider about this direction another
thing to consider when you have this is
measurement of the metabolites one of
the things that I mentioned earlier in
terms of looking at the the
interpretation of the results I said
people can shave pills into the urine so
somebody could know they're being tested
they can be diverting their medication
but they know that they need to test
positive so they could take a fingernail
or a penny or something and shave bits
of the the drug into the urine Cup now
that will likely give for an immunoassay
it would give you a very hot or very
strong positive for this but
what we would see then is if you were
pill shaping for instance you would not
see the metabolites that only happens if
somebody's ingesting the medication and
so being able to detect not just
morphine but normal Athene and morphine
glucagon I would certainly and have the
ability to differentiate between pill
shaving and actual ingestion of the
medication will touch briefly here as
Benza days being metabolism and if you
look at the three red circles each of
these so the temazepam and ox as a Pam
are drugs that are metabolites of
diazepam but there are also drugs that
can be prescribed on their own and it's
important the clinician know that if you
detect excessive Pam it is possible that
you're just seeing the metabolism of the
prescribed drug diazepam and they're not
going out and illicitly obtaining a
different substance and that's important
to keep in mind the last thing I want to
touch on with interpretation is
quantitative you're in toxicology so I
mentioned earlier that the that you can
generate a number with any of the
technologies where it's immunoassay but
more commonly with with mass
spectrometry based testing and there is
some discussion degree of discussion
around whether or not that those those
numbers can be used to confirm adherence
or or compliance with with the regimen
so I'd like to point to two studies
there are people that advocate for this
and argue for it and so there are a
couple of published studies that tried
to demonstrate that this is at least
feasible and so this is a study
published in 2009 around the an
algorithm to adjust mass spectrometry
based values and then looking at
distribution and in this study I'm you
can provide their efforts so you can go
look up the study itself if you want but
I'll give you the short version which
isn't a set of normal patients that are
not being treated for pain and this was
an inpatient study so the administration
of drug could be carefully controlled
differential metabolizers were excluded
right so they were they were tested for
their cytochrome p450 metabolites nism
and only wild-type metabolizers weren't
included these are patients that
received in the locks own blocks and
they were administered oxycodone
in a careful way but such that they
wouldn't receive any of the analgesic or
you know the high that you would get
from the drug and that they would be
kept safe of course yeah they weren't
taking any additional medications that
might induce a drug drug interactions so
this is sort of the what you would say
is the ideal best case scenario that
everybody metabolism that metabolizes
the drug relatively the same and so the
the goal here was to distinguish between
groups a B and C in doses carefully
administered in 80 milligrams 160
milligrams and 240 milligrams and so it
was a very carefully controlled well
performed scientific study and when the
when the investigators went to do the
analysis they compared the medians the
statistical medians at each of the three
populations and what you can see on this
as I put by the red lines that here are
the medians and when they looked at the
they did the 95 percent confidence
interval around the median and they
found that the that the median the
confidence intervals for the medians
when they took a conservative approach
did not overlap in other words they're
able to confidently distinguish between
the medians of the three populations but
the challenge is here that we don't
treat medians and we don't treat
statistical populations we treat
individuals and it what is obvious from
just you know looking at these
distributions is that the distributions
of the three populations overlap
significantly and so if you were able to
look at this and in fact when we
developed target ranges or reference
ranges in the central lab this is often
around not the 95% confidence interval
of a mean mean or median but it's around
the distribution of the population right
our reference intervals try to encompass
ninety-five percent of the patients
tested and now you look at that great
population overlap and you would look at
just a single this is an example of one
thing based on that result could you
really tell whether that patient was
taking or differentiate between a
patient taking 80 160 or 240 milligrams
of the drug and the answer of that would
be no you by itself you would not be
able to tell that based on the number
now a similar study was done with
hydrocodone this time using in a butyl
assay but I'll spare you most of the
details it was done very similarly an
ideal population and in this case what
you'll see is there's less overlap
between the populations but the result
is the same statistically the median and
their confidence intervals do not
overlap but when you look at these
populations you'd see that there would
be difficulty with certain values in
differentiating between 20 or 60
milligrams or 60 and 120 milligrams so
what you can see typically describe the
population and say if you fall in this
range you that is consistent with the
particular dose you couldn't say whether
they were taking a different dose or not
it would be very difficult to use that
to tell you whether or not they're
they're misusing the drug I believe and
that's not how we evaluate tests we
don't look at the median or confidence
intervals around the median what we look
at is how well we identify patient
populations and we think about things
like sensitivity and specificity or
positive or negative predictive value
and so a colleague of mine Dex tickle
this reference is wrong it's a paper
actually published it was electronically
available in 2012 but it if you look for
the actual reference for this now it's
in January 2013 and clinical
biochemistry and what they did was they
took the histogram in the in the in the
oxycodone paper from 2009 and they I
don't have a better way to say that they
reverse engineered the the figure so
that they could figure out the number of
patients or number of drug specimens and
and and then try to do some calculations
based on the results that they were able
to extract from the paper and then what
they did was construct six different
receiver operating characteristic curves
or ROC curves which is a more standard
measure of the ability of a test to
characterize one population versus
another and what you'll see here is in
the upper left-hand corner you're using
the lowest dose as the reference
population and the comparing to the mid
and high populations on the right the
upper right corner you do the same
analysis but using the middle dose as a
as a reference population and then in
the bottom panel what you'll see is
using the highest dose or the see
population to compare the lowest and
middle population and what you'll see
here is that best-case what you're
getting is an area of the curve just
under 0.8 which is not good if we think
about a good value for area under the
curve if it's 0.5 as you'll see in the
bottom panel that's basically a coin
flip and if you look at it's close to
the 0.55 I think was the actual one in
differentiating the highest dose from
the middle dose using the high dose as
the reference population and you see the
best that was done here was just short
of 0.8 again in that and if you try to
optimize getting to the optimal sense of
me versus specificity you'll see in the
upper right I'm sorry
upper left-hand panel a sensitivity of
0.7 for specificity to 0.75 if you
optimize but that's not really how we do
things more likely what we would do is
optimize either sensitivity or
specificity so in this case we would say
we would like to detect all the people
in Group A if we if we adjust the the
cutoff so that we will catch 95% of the
population so we have a 95% sensitivity
what is the specificity for that in
other words what are the odds if we if
we structure it so that we include 95%
of Group A what are the odds that we
exclude groups B and C those that are
taking different doses then in Group A
and you'll see that those odds are quite
low the specificity
is 0.14 and 0.27 for the a group if you
use the a group as the basis if you go
to B you'll you'll find not much better
the best one was actually using the C or
the high-dose as the basis group and
trying to differentiate that from the
lowest dose group or Group A and you see
the specificity at 95 percent
sensitivity would be forty percent and
so the odds for exclusion are not
terrific in fact everything is under 40
percent odds for exclusions so it is not
a great way to differentiate between
populations other than doing some
descriptive statistics again it's not
any better than saying this result can
be consistent with this particular drug
at the at the dose but it has to be used
in conjunction with risk assessment
tools and not a standalone there are no
quantitative at least as it stands with
quantitative urine drug levels so with
final thoughts of what we'd say is that
you know a misunderstanding of results
or wrong results can lead to
discontinuation of treatment for
patients with real pain this is really
important to get this right and to make
sure that things are interpreted
correctly in order to do this it's vital
to have an ongoing dialogue with pain
management physicians both so that we
can understand their needs and practices
but also so that we can communicate to
them what the limitations and an
appropriate testing practices are it's
it plays an important role in pain
management it's used to confirm patient
compliance with treatment guidelines and
also to minimize potential for abuse
diversion and any risks with specific
drug combinations with that I appreciate
your time and attention and I'll be
happy ooh I got I jumped the gun I'm
sorry one thing I did want to point out
before I turn it over for questions is
that there are laboratory guidance
documents coming me we do have two
documents I want to call your attention
to the first document is an
evidence-based lab medicine document
from the Academy of AACC and this is
this was done over the course of three
plus years where the the results were
reviewed from all the literature reports
it was then done systematically and we
graded the evidence
we open it to public comment it was
presented both at the American
Association for pain medicine as well as
the American Association for clinical
chemistry AACC both laboratorians and
clinicians contributed to the document
and this document should be available by
the end of the year another document
that we hope to have available by the
end of the year is the consensus
guideline again from both laboratories
and clinicians from the clinical lab
standards institute and this is done
many of us are serving on both of these
committees in order to harmonize the
guidelines that this document is more of
a consensus document around what is best
practice based on expert opinion rather
than scientific literature because the
end version is in many cases for many of
the questions we have the scientific
literature is just not complete and it's
quite sparse and now with that I'm happy
to turn it over to questions and again I
thank you for your attention dr. Clark
thank you for that informative
presentation now before we get started
on the question and answer session I
would like to remind our audience how to
submit questions you can submit
questions by typing them in the Q&A box
which can be found by clicking on the
green Q&A button at the lower left of
the presentation window we'll try to
answer as many questions as we can
kay dr. Clark our first question is
given the limitations of immunoassay
testing what is the benefit if using
this type of testing in pain management
patients versus going directly to mass
spectrometry based testing thank you
that question so I think one of the
challenges with the amino acid as we
pointed out is that it's not a
definitive type test but it is easy to
access it's automated and it's quite low
cost compared to chromatography mass
spectrometry and so I think particularly
in a low-risk population I can see the
value as we pointed out in the slides of
having doing more routine immunoassay
testing with less periodic mass
spectrometry based testing in a
high-risk population I would say again
this is not evidence-based but but
closer to consensus opinion I guess
maybe a consensus of one at this point
but I would think in a high-risk
population you would want to go directly
to chromatography mass spectrometry
based testing so that you can identify
the specific substances and make sure
that you get that answer right up front
dr. Clark what is the biggest challenge
for the laboratory and providing support
for pain management patient care
so I think the biggest challenge is
still making sure that clinicians
understand the limitations of what the
laboratory can do I think that we've
made a great deal of progress in terms
of our ability to support the clinicians
and we've done well in terms of we've
done well in terms of engaging the
clinicians but I think it's really
important to be able to communicate that
and it's really the dialogue and making
sure they understand that we cannot give
them you know the final stamp of
approval that they have to use their
clinical judgment and the risk
assessment tools in conjunction with
this so it's really hard I think to to
make sure that the clinicians and the
laboratory is on the same page that
they're on the same page but I think
that that's an area well it's the most
challenging I think it's an area where
we have the opportunity to make great
strides and we are doing so with the
guidelines and just with with current
practice thank you Christina just the
final comment is that I think that there
you know while we make great strides I
was just going to say on the last one
you know we still have a ways to go and
it's going to require a lot of
cooperation but I think that through
more technology developments and better
clinical studies we can really do we can
really work together to find better ways
to from the laboratory perspective to
support the clinicians but most
importantly patients so again thank you
for your time and attention
thank you to laberd's for making today's
educational webcast possible today's
webcast will be available for on-demand
viewing through February of 2017 you
will receive an email from lab roots
alerting you when this webcast will be
available for replay we invite you to
forward that announcement to your
colleagues you may have missed today's
live event thanks for joining us and we
hope to see you next time goodbye